people have been in my comments saying
Kiki's having a baby Kiki's pregnant and
I want to set the record straight I am
Kiki Palmer is going to be a mom oh my
gosh come on let's talk about it the
actress made her Saturday Night Live
debut over the weekend and during her
opening monologue she seemingly
attempted to hide the news while wearing
a long Blazer
thank you very much I'm so excited to be
here in New York
then just moments later Kiki made the
big reveal and showed off her baby bump
I'm especially glad to be here though
because
there's some rooms going around
people have been in my comments saying
Kiki's having a baby Kiki's pregnant and
I want to set the record straight I am
while fans have been speculating the 29
year old's pregnancy for some time Kiki
made her SNL appearance a moment to
laugh about it
just say no it is bad with people on the
internet spread rumors about you y'all
but it's even worse when they're correct
try so hard to keep it on the down low
because I got a lot of stuff going on
you know people kept coming up to me
congratulations I'm like can y'all stop
I got a liquor sponsorship on the line
that's a chat clear then we can get to
the damn baby shower as for those who
can't shake the idea of Kiki becoming a
mom she shares this message some people
feel a little weird about me having a
baby because I was a drowned actor I
just want to say look I'm 29 I'm grown
okay I have sex I own a home I stormed
the cap capital on January 6th
after the announcement Kiki showed some
love to her quote other half boyfriend
Darius Jackson and a post on Instagram
she shared a carousel of photos of her
time on the sketch comedy show thanking
the writers and more for the opportunity
Lynn gave her man a special Shout Out
quote this year has taken me for a ride
and how cool my baby and I are already
doing it together thank you to my other
half Darius Jackson for giving me the
things that only true Unity can bring
already know Darius was by Kiki's side
during her SNL hosting gig and after the
show he took a moment to send some love
to the mama-to-be your girl is ready for
the park Kiki and Darius have mainly
kept their relationship private but when
Instagram official last year when he
posted a birthday tribute to the actress
cheers to the couple as they look
forward to welcoming their first child
together this has been the biggest
blessing and I am so excited guys I'm
gonna be a mom
[Applause]
[Music]